Today's topic is one of
the most important concepts
in this area, and it
is called atomicity.
And what we are going
to do is spend time
understanding what
this is as a concept
and then understanding how to
achieve atomicity in systems.
And recall that the main
goal is to handle "failures",
and that is what we talked
about the last time.
And we came up with a bunch
of different ways of thinking
about failures and
how to cope with it.
And one idea that we saw the
last time was an idea involving
replicating a
component, let's say
a disk or any component
whose failure you
wish to cope with and
vote on the results.
And so the idea is that if
you are not exactly sure what
the right answer should be--
If you are not sure whether
any given component is working
correctly or not,
replicate that component
and then give them all the same
input, see what output appears
and then vote on the results.
And we did see that these
things are pretty sophisticated,
but the main problem
with replicate plus vote
is that often it is extremely
expensive to build and very,
very hard to get right.
And, second, it often
does not actually work.
For example, if you just
take a software program,
a software module and you
make 100 copies or 95 copies
of that software
module and give them
all the same input and
then vote on the output,
if you have a bug in
one of the modules
and it is a bug that
is actually replicated
in all of the modules
then all of the replicas
are going to give you
the same wrong answer.
So the key assumption behind
replicating and voting
is that the replicas are
independent of each other
and have independent
modes of failure.
And that may not be true
in all of your modules.
And so the way we are going
to deal with this problem,
and even though it is possible
to design software systems
where the replicas are, in
fact, independent of each other,
it will turn out that
it is quite expensive
to do in many cases.
So what we are going to do, to
relax this assumption of having
a system which handles
failures by giving
the same input to multiple
outputs and then voting on it,
we are going to relax
that and instead
look at a different concept
called "recoverability".
And the idea here
is rather is rather
than to try to replicate modules
so that to the higher layers
it looks as if the underlying
module has never failed
because you have replicated
it, the idea here is to allow
the underlying module to fail.
But have it fail, typically
in a fail fast manner
so that you can
detect the failure,
and then arrange for that
module to be restarted.
And when it restarts
the idea is to make it
so that the module
does something
such that in the end
the state of the system,
after it does that
thing, usually some kind
of recovery procedure
is that you can get back
to using that module.
So it is a little bit
like rather than try
to build, you know, the analogy
might be something like this.
You might imagine, let's say
there is a little child who
is learning to walk.
One approach for
nature to have adopted
would have been to try to make
it so the child never falls.
And there is a lot of complexity
associated with always
keeping that child walking.
Or, alternatively,
you could have
a story or a method by
which every once in a while
the child falls but then has a
plan to get up from that fall
and then restart.
So that is the plan that
we are going to adopt.
And this notion here is
called recoverability.
And the general
plan is going to be
that if you have a module M1
which invokes another module M2
and M2 were to fail then
the idea is that M2 fails
and then it recovers and
you restart the module.
And you want to make sure that
M2 is left in a situation,
once it recovers, where
there is no partial state.
And I will define that more
precisely as we go along today.
But the main idea is going
to be to insure that there
is no vestige of
previous computations
that are in the
middle of being run.
So the state of the
system, when it recovers,
is at a well-understood
point so that M1
can continue to use that.
So there is no
"partial" state where
partial is in quotes here.
And we will talk about
what it means for something
to be in a partial state.
The idea is to prevent
that from happening.
So we are going to
do this by starting
with an example,
and the same example
that I mentioned the last time
which was a transfer of money
from one bank
account to another.
There is a "from" account,
there is a "to" account
and some dollar "amount".
And you want to transfer
money from "from" to "to"
and it is whatever
the "amount" is.
And the problem
here is, of course,
that in the middle of transfer
this procedure might fail,
the system might
crash and you might
be left in a situation where
a part of this transfer
has already run.
To take a specific
example, here is
an example of what the transfer
procedure might look like.
It takes a "from" and
a "to" and an "amount".
And the first thing
it does is to read.
Assume that all of this
data is stored on disk.
It reads from the "from"
account and then it reduces,
it debits the amount from the
"account" and then writes back.
And it does the same
thing to the "to" account.
So in the end, if this
procedure completely
ran, then "from" account would
be reduced by "amount" and "to"
account would be
enhanced by "amount".
Of course, the problem is
you might have a failure
anywhere in the middle.
And, as a concrete
example, if a crash
were to happen after the
first three lines shown above,
if you owned this account
you would not be very happy
because you just lost
some money from an account
and nothing happened.
No other account got
money added to it,
and this is the problem
that we want to avoid.
If you think about this for
a moment, what you would like
intuitively is that if a
crash like this were to happen
and the system were to
recover and come back up,
there are really only two
states that the system should
be in for the system
to really be correct
and to meet what your
intuition might expect.
Either this procedure must
completely be finished, that is
the state of the system must be
the same as if this procedure
completely ran and finished,
or the state of the system
must be such that the
procedure never ran at all.
It is not at all OK to let
the state of the system
be equal to whatever the
state was, in this example,
at the time the crash happened.
What you want is a kind of
all or nothing behavior.
And, of course, if the crash
happened as I have shown here,
there is no way for you to have
prevented those lines of code
from being wrong.
Those lines of code ran and
then the crash happened.
So what you really need
is a way by which you
can back out of these changes.
What the system needs
is a way by which
when the system crashes and
then recovers from the crash,
during failure
recovery the system
has to have a way to back out
of whatever changes it has made.
In other words, what
we want is a concept
called recoverability.
So a more precise
definition of recoverability
is shown on this slide, and
let me just read it out.
A composite sequence of
steps, which we are also
going to use the word
"action" for, an action is
recoverable if, from the point
of view of the module that
invokes this action,
this sequence either
always completes or aborts.
That is if it fails and then
backs out, aborts in a way
such that it appears that
the sequence had never
started to begin with.
And, in particular,
what this means
is that if a failure were
to happen in the middle
when the system
recovers, it better
have a plan of backing
out the changes.
In other words, of
aborting this action.
The way you think
about recoverability,
the simple way to think about
it is do it all or not at all.
And our goal is to try to
somehow come up with a way
to achieve this goal.
And before we get into a
solution to this problem
there are a few other
concepts to discuss,
and they will turn out to be
very related to each other.
And the second concept
after recoverability
that is very closely
related to this idea
has to do with
concurrent actions.
Imagine for a moment that
you had the same transfer
procedure as in this example but
you had two transfers running
at the same time
and they happened
to act on the same
data items like that.
Let's say that the first
transfer moved from a savings
account to a checking
account, it moved $100.
And the second one moved
from savings to checking,
it moved $200.
And let's say at the
beginning S was $1,000.
And, of course as you
recall from several lectures
ago, when you have these
interleave sequences,
these two threads
running the steps
that these threads
are made of might
be interleave in arbitrary
order if you don't
have a plan to isolate them.
And, in particular, you might
have many results that show up.
And one result
that might show up
is both of these transfers
running concurrently
read $1,000 from "from"
account and then both of them
debit by $100 and
$200 respectively.
So at the end of it you might
be left with either $800 or $900
left in the account
when the right answer is
to have been left
intuitively, if you ran
both these transfers
you would like to see
$700 left in that account.
So what you
intuitively want here
is if this is the
first action, A1,
and this is the second action,
A2, what you would like to see
is a sequence--
You don't actually
care what the order
is between these two transfers.
I mean you are
transferring money
from one account to another
and you are doing two of these.
You do not actually
care in this example,
and it will turn
out all the examples
that we are going to be
talking about with this notion
that you are not really going
to care what the order is.
Either order is perfectly
fine, but the order
should be as if it is equivalent
to either A1 before A2 or A2
before A1.
And that is what we would like.
And, of course, some naīve way
to achieve this is to insure
that exactly one
action runs at a time,
it finishes and then
the second one runs,
but that is kind of going
to be no fun for us to do.
It is the right
simplest solution,
but we are going to want to
improve concurrency as we had
wanted to several lectures ago.
So we are going to
come up with ways
of getting higher
performance than running one
after the other.
But the net effect is if you
run it in some serial order,
in some sequential
order of the actions.
That is the result of
running concurrent action has
to be the same as
some serial ordering
of the individual actions.
And this idea of A1 before A2
or A2 before A1 has a name.
It is called "isolation".
And you should distinguish
that in your mind
clearly from recoverability.
So a more precise
definition of isolation
is essentially
what I said before.
The composite sequence
of steps is isolated
if its effect from the
point of view of its invoker
is the same as if the
action occurred either
completely before or completely
after every other isolated
action.
And the simple way
to understand this
is you either do it all
before or do it all after.
That is the net effect has to be
the same as doing it all before
or doing it all after.
And it is different from
recoverability which is
really do it all or not at all.
Now, when you have a
system that satisfies
both recoverability
and isolations--
The way to understand
this is both of these
really, although
they are talking
about different concepts,
this is saying all or nothing
and this is saying all before
or all after, both of these
are getting at the same
intuitive idea which
is that somehow there is a
sequence of steps, for example,
in this transfer procedure there
will be sequences of steps.
And somehow you want to make
it look as if, for each action,
the sequence of steps is not
visible to somebody invoking
the action because you do
not want the person invoking
this action for recoverability.
You do not want him to
know that it is build out
of a sequence of steps.
And if a failure
happens in the middle,
you do not want the
invoker of that action
to see some partial state.
Likewise, when you have
concurrent actions running
together, you do not want
the different invokers
of that action to somehow
see this muddled result
of the interleaving.
You want them to
only see the results
of running these actions
one after the other.
What you really
trying to achieve
for both of these
concepts, although they
are distinct concepts,
is to hide the fact
that this action is a
composite sequence of steps.
You want to make it look as if
it is quite [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And this idea of wanting
something to look
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is
called "atomicity".
And we are going to be
basically hiding the fact
that it is composite.
So more precisely
for this course,
we are going to use the
word "atomic" to mean
recoverable and isolated.
And I am going to
say for this course
because these terms have been
used in various different ways
for at least probably
more than 30 years
and I think it is about
time we made these precise.
In the literature, you
will see the word atomic
to often mean recoverable.
And sometimes, and
this is unfortunate,
you will see the word
consistent to mean isolated.
And, in particular, you
will run into this confusion
when you read the paper
for recitation on Thursday,
the System R paper.
The problem is those
terms used historically
have not been used
in a very precise way
so we will define it precisely.
When we say something
is atomic, in general
we mean both recoverable
and isolated.
When we mean only
one of them, we
will say atomic with
respect to recoverability
or recoverable, atomic
with respect to isolation
or isolated.
And, like I said, atomic means
recoverable and isolated.
The general plan
is to hide the fact
that an action is built out of
composite sequence of steps.
Now, to add to this
confusion of terminology,
there are actually two other
terms or two other properties
that you often want
from actions in addition
to recoverability and isolation.
And these two other
properties are
provided by many
database systems
which are one of the most
common users of these concepts.
The most common system that
provides atomicity, one example
is a database system.
Now, many, many systems
provide atomicity.
For example, every computer
does it in its instruction set.
You often want
your instructions,
from the point of view of the
invoker of the instruction,
to be atomic.
So we are going to be
designing techniques
that, in general, operate across
the whole range of systems.
But database systems are
of particular interest
because they are very common
and they exercise these concepts
to a high degree.
And two other concepts
that many systems provide,
the first one is "consistency".
And it is unfortunate that the
word consistency was previously
used, to some extent,
to mean isolated.
So it is important not to
get into that confusion.
In some old papers when
you see consistency,
you should realize
that what they really
are talking about isolated,
A1 before A2 or A2 before A1.
But we will mean by
consistency, and we
will get into this next
week, is that there
is some invariant for the
application that is often using
atomicity that is maintained.
For example, in a
banking application,
if you take the
transfer examples,
isolated means that
you want the result
to be as if the transfers
ran in some serial order.
Consistent means that
there might be a high level
notion that the designer
of this banking application
might have wanted, such as a
bank might have a rule that
says that at the end of each day
every checking account should
have an amount that
is at least 10%
of the corresponding
savings account.
Now, during the
middle of the day
there might be
individual actions that
transiently violate that rule.
But, at various
points, the designer
might wish to insure that
a rule is the checking
account must have at least
a certain amount of money,
some fraction of
the savings account.
Or in some payroll
application for a company,
they are modifying the
payroll and giving raises
to various people,
but they might
have a rule that says
you could give whatever
raise you want but every manager
must make at least 5% more
than all of his or
her direct reports.
You might have a rule like that.
All of these are applications
of an invariant that
correspond to the
consistency of the data that
is being maintained in
this example in a database.
And you can use database systems
to provide these consistency
rules.
But that is different
from isolation.
Isolation just
says that there has
to be some equivalent serial
ordering in which things run.
And the fourth property after
recoverability, isolation
and consistency is "durability".
Durability basically
says that the data
should last for as long as--
It's an application-specific
concept, but what it says
is the data must
last for as long
as some pre-defined duration.
For example, you might
store data in a database.
And, in many
databases, you really
want it to last "forever".
But in reality it is very hard
to make things last forever
so you might define that
the data in this database
must last for three years, and
you work hard to preserve that.
Or you might have an
application that as long
as the thread is running
you want the data to last,
but after the
thread is terminated
you do not actually
care about the data.
And that is a different
notion of durability.
But both of these have talked
about the lifetime with which
you want to preserve data.
Now, when you have a system
that provides recoverability
and isolation, that is
atomicity, consistency
and durability,
then we are going
to call that a transaction.
A set of actions, each
of which is recoverable,
that are isolated
from each other, that
has a notion of consistency
and can achieve it
and where the data has
durability, those actions
are called transactions.
And many database systems work
hard to provide transactions,
which means they provide
all of these features.
But it is certainly
possible, and we
will look at many examples
where you can just
design systems that have just
recoverability and isolation.
And we will not even worry
about these other notions.
That is what we will start with.
We do not want to solve all
of the problems at once.
We will start with the
easier set of problems
and then build from there.
Today, and on
Wednesday, our plan
is to come up with ways of
achieving recoverability.
So that is what we are
going to start doing.
The general approach
for how we are
going to achieve
recoverability of modules
is, and recall that
the problem here
is M2 fails and then M1
somehow discovers its failure
and then when it
restarts you do not want
any partial state to be kept.
The general plan is to design
modules to be failed fast.
You need a way to discover
that things are not working,
and that is the scope of
the kinds of systems we
are going to be dealing with.
And then once the system's
failure is detected
and then you restart the
system or it recovers,
you run some kind of
a repair procedure.
This is in general you run
some kind of repair procedure
that allows that failed
module to recover
and then it restarts
where restarts
means it allows,
M1 in this case,
allows invokers to start running
on that system, on that module.
We are going to do
this in three steps.
The first thing
we are going to do
is to look at a very specific
special case of this problem
which is realize that
all of these having
to do with partial state
occur because there
is some state, once
a module has crashed
there is some state
that it has remaining.
So if it just recovered
and started running again
without doing something
then that partial state
is visible to the
invoker of that module.
Now, if the state were all a
volatile state like in just
RAM, for example,
and a thread crashed,
if it was in its virtual
memory and the thread crashed
and it recovered then
you do not really
have to worry about this
because all of the state
anywhere has gone away.
Primarily, we were
worried about state
that lasts across failures.
And an example of
that is the state
that is maintained on this,
just as a concrete example.
We are going to start first by
obtaining a recoverable sector.
Basically coming up with the
scheme that allows us to do
reads and writes
of a single sector
of a disk in a recoverable way.
So we are going to define two
procedures, a recoverable "put"
that allows you to
put stuff, write stuff
onto a single sector of a
disk and the recoverable
"get" that allows
you to read stuff
of a single sector of a disk
in a way that is recoverable.
And the hard problem
here is going
to be that as the
system is crashing,
for a variety of
reasons, bad data might
get written to a sector.
If you just took a regular
sector of your disk,
let's say that the
operating system
is trying to write something
into a disk sector,
somebody turns off the
power and random stuff
might get written
out onto the disk.
And so when the
system comes back up,
the reader of that sector
might get some garbage value,
a result of some partial write.
So that is what we are
going to try to avoid.
So we will do that first.
And that is for next
time, to complete
the recoverability story.
We are going to use this
solution as a building-block
for a more general
solution because it is not
going to be enough for us to
just be able to read and write
single sectors in
a recoverable way
because how many applications
use only one sector of a disk?
What you would like
to do is to make sure
that you have a
general solution that
works across all of the data
that is being written and read.
We are going to use that to
come up with two schemes.
The first scheme uses an idea
called a "version history".
And a second scheme uses an idea
called "logging" using logs.
And both of these
schemes will turn out
to be very general
and useful and work,
but both of these
schemes basically
will use this technique as
a bootstrapping technique.
And so we need a solution
here anyway because we
are going to build on that to
develop a more sophisticated
solution for the general case.
And so today we are going to
start with a special case.
A, because it is
a building block,
and, B, because it will
turn out to show us
a rule that we are going to
religiously following in coming
up with systematic solutions
to work in a more general case
when you have more than
one sector being read.
So let's write out the
assumptions in the model
here for this solution.
The first assumption
we are going to make,
since we are dealing with
recoverability and not
with isolation.
We are going to deal
with isolation next week.
The first assumption
we will make
is that there is no
concurrency, and we will come up
with different
solutions for dealing
with people concurrently trying
to write the same sector.
And this is an assumption
we will revisit
in a couple of weeks
to show you how
to actually achieve this goal.
But we will assume that there
are no hardware failures,
no hardware errors.
For example, the
appendix to Chapter 8,
which we have assigned
for reading later
on in the semester,
actually shows two methods,
"careful put" and "careful
get" that actually
deal with a variety
of hardware problems.
For example, every sector has
a disk "checks-them" on it.
If you wrote bad data
and something happened
in the middle of that write and
then someone went back and read
that sector, they would
discover that it is bad
because the checks-them
would not match.
Now, the appendix
to this chapter, 9B,
has a more careful
description of how
you deal with a
variety of errors
so that you can achieve this
careful put and careful get
of a disk sector.
Assume for now that there
are no hardware errors,
there is no decay of data
on the disk and so on.
It will turn out the problem
is still interesting,
that it is not easy to
achieve a recoverable put
and get even though
the hardware is fine.
And that is because there
are software errors.
And, in particular,
the model here
is that you have
some application
and then you have
the operating system.
And the operating
system has a buffer
here of data that it is
waiting to write onto disk.
Then you have a disk and
that is a disk sector.
The problem might be
that as a failure occurs
there is something that happens,
an error or something that gets
triggered in the
operating system
so the buffer gets
corrupted and then there
is some bad data that gets
written out onto the sector.
That is the kind of problem
that we want to protect against.
The fact that your
hardware is perfect
does not actually
solve this problem
because this buffer itself has
been corrupted or something
happens during the
process of writing
this buffer to the sector
so the data itself is bad,
and that is what we
want to protect against.
We are going to build on
something that I have already
talked about.
We are going to build on two
procedures, careful put that
puts to a sector,
it puts some data,
and the corresponding careful
get which reads from a sector
and returns the data
that is on that sector.
And the assumption
is that careful
put and get, once you
give it some data there
are no hardware failures for
you to worry about anymore.
The solution we are going
to take to this problem
is to realize that
when a failure happens,
for example, somebody
turns off the power switch
and this buffer gets corrupted,
when the operating systems does
a write to that
sector, the sector
might be left in a state
that does not actually
correspond to the
data that was intended
to put onto that sector.
And so when the system
recovers you are sort of stuck
because this data in the sector
contains some values in it that
do not actually correspond
to any actual intended put
of the data, any intended
write of the data.
What this suggests is that
a solution to this problem
must involve a
copy of some kind.
You must make sure that if you
have just one copy of the data
and you write to it and
something fails in the middle
and you do not have
a plan to back out
to an earlier working version
that was correct you are stuck.
That suggests that we
better have a solution that
involves a copy of data.
Later on we will see how
to systematically [develop
a rule?] based on this.
The idea here is very simple.
The way we are going to achieve
a "recoverable get of a sector"
is actually to build a single
sector, a recoverable sector
out of three sectors.
The first sector here is going
to have one copy of the data,
the second sector is going to
have another copy of the data
and we are going to have
a third sector which
is going to act as a flag
that allows us to choose one
version or the other version.
Let me call this D0,
let me call this D1
and let me call
this the "chooser".
Assume that at some point in
time D0 has proper data on it.
The idea now is going to
be that anybody reading it,
the chooser is going to
contain the value zero in it.
Now, anybody reading is
going to read from D0.
Anybody writing
in recoverable put
is not allowed to write
to D0 because that is
what people are reading from.
Instead, they will write to D1.
When the chooser
value is zero, they
will start writing into D1.
The plan is going to be that
if that write succeeds properly
then what we will do
is go ahead and change
the chooser from zero to
a one, and then people
will start reading from one.
But if that write were
to fail in the middle,
if the power fails or
something like that,
D1 will be left in sort of
a weird intermediate state.
But that is OK because
nobody is really
going to be reading from D1.
They are all going to be reading
from D0 because the chooser has
not yet been changed.
The only other thing
we have to worry about
is now we are OK, as long
as the failure happens,
if the failure
happens in the middle
here somewhere where we are
writing D1 we are OK because we
have not touched the chooser.
If the failure happens at
the end of writing D1--
So we have written D1
and then we have not yet
started writing the chooser
and a failure happens here,
we are still OK
because everybody
will be reading from zero.
And that is not going
to have garbage in it.
It is not going to have
the latest value in it.
But that is OK.
We never said that we
should see the latest value
for recoverability to hold.
It is going to be OK for
us to be reading from D0
and continue to read from D0.
And really the
correctness of this
boils down to understanding
what will happen
when a failure happens
during the middle of writing
this sector.
You are starting to
write the chooser sector
and the system fails.
And we do not have to worry
about that because now we
have written D1 completely
and a failure happened
in the middle of that.
To understand that,
we will get back
to understanding the
correctness of it,
but it helps to see what
pseudo code looks like.
So that is what put looks like.
To do a put, you first
read the chooser sector
and then you put
into the other place.
This which here
is the thing that
tells you what the value
of the chooser sector is.
It tells you which of the
two copies to write into.
And then after you do the
careful put, if which is zero,
you put it to one, if which
is one, you put it to zero.
After that you
twiddle a bit and then
you do a put onto
the chooser sector.
The get is actually easier.
You just look at what the
value is of the chooser sector
and then get it from
the corresponding place.
Now, there is a line here, the
second line of this pseudo code
which says status "not-OK".
So status not-OK
is the key thing.
If status not-OK is
what happens when
a failure happens in the middle
of writing the chooser sector.
Let's say a failure happens
on this pseudo code,
I already explained why there is
no problem if a failure happens
until you get to the
last line, until you
get to the careful put
of the chooser sector.
Until that line is executed
nobody sees the new data.
Everybody doing a
get is continuing
to see the old data, not
the new data that just
got written with careful put.
After this careful put
executes and returns then
everybody is going to see the
new data because the chooser
sector has been
correctly changed.
The only tricky
part to worry about,
we have reduced this problem of
the slightly more general case
of writing these sectors
and switching between then
to this specific
problem of figuring out
what happens if a failure occurs
in the middle of the chooser
sector's write.
If a failure happens here,
one of the common things
that could happen is that this
particular sector's checks-them
does not match the data
that is written here.
So when you do a
get of that sector
here, in the first
line up there, when
you do a careful
get of that, you
will find that the
checks-them does not
match so it returns
a status of not-OK.
If the status is
not OK, you will
have to figure out which
of the two copies to put.
Now, the reason
you can pick either
and you can arbitrarily pick
read the data from sector zero.
But you could pick
either of these.
And the reason is
it OK to pick either
is you know for sure that the
failure must have happened here
while writing this
chooser sector.
And because there are no
concurrent threads going on,
you are assured that there is
no failure that happened here
while writing D0, nor
was there any failure
that occurred here
while writing D1
because the assumption
we have made
is that there is no concurrency.
A system crashes and
recovers and discovers
that there is a failure, or
the careful-get of the chooser
sector did not quite
work out, did not
give you a status of
OK, that it was not
OK then you know the failure
happened while writing here.
And what that means is it
is perfectly OK for you
to read from either version.
Both of those
correspond to a write
to that individual sector that
did not fail in the middle.
And it does not matter
which of the two you pick.
That is the reason why this
approach basically works.
And if you look
at this solution,
this copy idea is actually
a pretty critical idea
for all of our solutions to
achieving recoverability.
And it is going
to lead to a rule
that we are going to
call the "Golden Rule
of Recoverability".
The rule says never
modify the only copy.
If you were asked to
come up with a way
to achieve something that is
recoverable, one guideline,
this is unfortunately not
a sufficient condition.
But a necessary condition is
that if you have something,
and you only have one copy of
that which you end up writing,
then chances are that if a
failure happens in the middle
of writing that one copy
you cannot back out of it
so your scheme would not work.
So never modify the
only copy of anything,
that is the general rule.
Now, there is another
point to observe about
this recoverable disk write.
And that has to do with
that careful put line.
Write before that
line, everybody else
reading this recoverable
sector using recoverable
get sees the old
version of data.
Right after that line has
finished, everybody reading it
sees the new data.
That line is an
example of something
that we will repeatedly
visit and use
called a "commit point".
The successful
completion of that line
insures that everybody
else following doing gets
will see the data that
was written by this put.
And before that line is run,
everybody else following
will see the older
version of the data.
Now, if a failure occurs
in the middle of that line
then the answer depends on what
the recovery procedure does.
And one approach might
be that the invoker
of this module, the person who
originally did the disk write--
If a failure happens in
the middle of the write,
one plan might be that the
invoker of that disk write,
upon recovery, tries the write
again, tries the put again.
And the way he
tries the put is he
first does a get and
sees what answers return.
If the answer is
the new answer then
he says OK everything is fine.
If the answer is
the old answer then
he says I am going
to retry the put.
And this is an
example of something
we saw the last time which
is "temporal redundancy".
You can retry things.
Not only can you
replicate in space,
but you can retry things in
time which is the idea here
for achieving fault-tolerance.
An example of this idea
called a commit point
is that careful put line.
And, in general,
a commit point is
a point in a recoverable
action, in this case.
And it will turn out
to be an idea that
is useful for isolated actions
and for transactions more
generally.
But a commit point is a point
where before the commit point
other people do not see
the results of your action.
And after the commit
point successfully
finishes everybody sees
the results of your action,
and that is the definition
of a commit point.
Now we have to generalize this
idea because what we have seen
is a scheme.
By the way, is this
clear to everybody?
Do you have any questions
about recoverable put and get?
What does that mean?
No questions or not clear?
All right.
Good.
Now we have to
generalize this idea
because the class of programs
where you could just sort
of read and write from one
sector is quite limited.
And so to generalize this idea
of what we are going to do
is to change the
programming model
for writing recoverable
actions a little bit.
Ideally, what you would
like to be able to do,
the model we are
going to try to get at
is to be able to
take a procedure
and begin recoverable action
in front of that procedure,
write code for that
procedure and just
say end recoverable action
and sort of magically end up
with a model where the set
of steps in that action
becomes recoverable.
And it will turn out we
have come very, very close
to achieving this
very general model
by making some
slight assumptions,
or requiring the
programmer to make
some small assumptions in the
way they write their programs.
And this generalization
to more general actions
that are recoverable,
generalizing
from a single sector uses
this idea of a commit point.
The way this is
going to work out
is the programmer, for
any recoverable action,
he or she is going to end up
writing this special function
call called begin
recoverable action
and then writing the code
for that recoverable action.
And then at some point in the
middle of this code calling
a function called "commit".
And the idea is that
until this commit
is called nobody else sees
the results of this action.
Which means that if
a failure happened,
upon crash recovery or
once the system restarts,
the result would be as if none
of the steps of this action
ever happened.
So they are called commit.
And then once commit finished
then no matter what happens,
a failure could happen
and the system restarts,
but once commit is called
and it returns then you
are guaranteed that all
other actions see the state
changes made by this action.
So this is a special call.
And then after commit they
might have some other lines
that they write and then they
end the recoverable action.
Now, in many, many cases,
the very last thing
that is done before the
end recoverable action
is the commit.
But, in general, you might
have other things here.
And it will turn out that you
cannot do arbitrary things
here.
For example, you cannot do disk
writes that you want to make
recoverable over here because
the moment you do that,
by definition, if a crash
happens after a commit,
we do not have a plan
to back out of it.
Because the semantics
were that once
a commit is done
then no matter what
happens the state
of the system is
as if all of the things
in this action finished.
The discipline is going to
be, this thing is called
the "pre-commit phase" and
this thing here is called
the "post-commit phase".
And so the idea is that
in the pre-commit phase
you should always be
prepared to back out.
Because, by definition, if the
failure occurs before commit
is called the result is going to
be as if nothing ever happened,
which means that any
change you make here
you better religiously
follow that never
modify the only copy rule
and be prepared to back out.
In the post-commit
phase, conversely, you
don't have the
option to back out
so you better make sure
that once you get here
you just run to completion.
If a failure occurs out
here and you restart,
you better make sure that
you can run to completion.
In fact, there are a
few other restrictions
out in the post-commit phase.
Let me do this by an example.
In the pre-commit phase, because
you have to be prepared to back
out, it often means in practice
that you cannot be sending
messages out onto the network.
You can maintain
your local state
but you have a way
to back out of that.
But if you are sending messages
out onto the network and you
do not have a bigger
story to deal with it--
We will talk later about nesting
atomic actions within one
another or nesting
recoverable actions within one
another in a few
lectures from now.
But, in the simple model, if
you do anything that you cannot
back out of such as sending
a network packet then you are
stuck.
So all of that stuff like
printing out checks or firing
a bullet or things like that,
that you cannot back out
of, you better put out here.
All the things that you
can back out of go here.
Likewise, nothing you can
back out of can go here.
Because, once you reach
here and a failure happens,
you have to continue
to completion.
What that means is in the
first commit phase, really,
you cannot do very many things.
I mean you can do things that
do not really have, for example,
you can do things that
are OK to keep doing.
For example, you can do
item put and operation
so that if a failure happens
here and you recover then
you know that you
are out at this point
so you could keep retrying those
actions over and over again
until you insure
that it completes.
But those are the only rules.
There is a pre-commit phase
and a post-commit phase.
There is a commit that
is explicitly called.
Now, in addition
there is another call
that a programmer can make
or that the system can
invoke automatically and
that is called "abort".
For example, when you are moving
money from savings account
to checking account in
that transfer example,
if you discover in the
middle here that you do not
have enough funds to
cover that transfer,
you could just decide to
abort the recoverable action.
And what that means is
that abort automatically
will insure that the
state of the system
is at the point right
before the start
of the recoverable action.
Whatever changes were made
in the middle until abort
was called end up backing out.
Now, abort might also be
invoked by the system.
In a database, there is somebody
booking airline tickets, car
reservations and all of that,
and you discover in the middle
that you are not
actually able to find
a hotel for the same dates.
So you might just abort the
whole process, control C
the thread you
are running, which
means that all of the
work that has been done
has to be backed out.
And so the system would
normally implement that
by aborting all of the changes
that you have made so far.
It will back out of
your car reservation,
back out of your airline
reservation and so on.
So abort is called in a
few different contexts.
Sometimes by the program
itself, sometimes
by the system to
free up resources,
sometimes by the user of
your, say, transaction system.
I am not going to get into how
we implement recoverable action
today, but this
programming model
is important to understand.
I do want to mention
one thing going back
to this idea of isolation
that we talked about.
If you recall,
isolation is this idea
that you have two actions or
multiple actions whose net
effect is as if they ran
in some sequential order,
some serial order,
A1 before A2 or A2
before A1 for all implantation
of A1, A2, A3, etc.
Now, this idea is actually
very closely related
but not the same as stuff
we have seen before.
Earlier in the
semester we looked
at ways in which you have
multiple threads that
need to be synchronized
with each other.
And we actually did look
at isolation as a concept
then but we specifically
focused on things
like sequence
coordination where you
want to have one thread run
before the other thread or one
thread run off of
the other thread.
For example, in a
producer-consumer relationship.
The point is that in
one significant respect,
achieving this idea of
isolation for actions
is harder than achieving
sequence coordination.
And the reason it is
harder is that everybody
who writes an isolated action,
in general, does not know,
any given isolated
action does not
know what other actions
there are in the system.
So you might have 25
different actions all of which
are touching the same
data, but no single action
is aware of all of
these other actions.
That is very different
from sequence coordination.
In sequence coordination,
there is one or two
or a small number of threads
that are actually aware
of each other.
And there is a single
programmer that is actually
designing these things
to specifically interact
with each other in some fashion,
so this thread runs and then
this other one
runs after the data
has been produced and so on.
In that sense, this
kind of isolation
is harder to achieve because
each individual action does not
know which other
action there are.
But, yet, you want to
achieve this sequential goal.
Now, in one other
respect, actually
isolated actions are easier
than sequence coordination.
And the significant way
in which they are easier
is they are easier
for programmers.
Because we are not worried about
coordinating different actions
with each other, once you design
a system that inside the system
deals with ways of
achieving isolation,
the programmers do not have to
think about locks and unlocks
and acquiring and releasing
locks or other ways
in which they control access to
variables that might be shared.
What this means is that if we
can design isolated actions
right and we do not worry
about any serial order,
A1 can run before
A2 or A2 before A1,
then it makes life a lot
easier for a programmer.
And our goal is to
come up with ways
of achieving recoverability
and isolation that
require very little
from a programmer that
wants these properties.
It is a little bit
like pixy dust.
You might write
a general program
and come in and just put a
begin recoverable action,
end recoverable action and make
a few changes to your program.
Or you might just say
begin isolated action,
end isolated action,
and magically
the system achieves isolation
or recoverability for you.
It can make life much
easier for a programmer
but it is a harder
problem for us
because no single
action is aware of all
of the other actions
in the system.
Next time we will see how to
achieve recoverability and then
isolation and transactions.
Design Project 2 is
out on the website now.
And the main thing for you
to make sure you do this week
is get project partners and
send a list of team members
to your teaching assistant
by Thursday's recitation.
Thanks.